the severe weather also brought nearly
seven inches of rain Yanks to parts of
Oklahoma Kansas Missouri and Texas last
night causing life-threatening flash
flooding there that's right flash flood
watches extend for 650 miles from Kansas
all the way to Illinois CBS this
morning's lead national correspondent
David Pegg know is in hominy Oklahoma
where dozens had to be rescued or
evacuated David good morning Tony good
morning this is what you get for being
the lead standing in the rain because
this is the top story right now over the
last 12 hours flash flooding has been
the story we woke up in Moore Oklahoma
outside Oklahoma City drove two hours to
hominy and this is what we've started to
find this is the same ditch that six
hours ago had flooded the street left a
mother and her daughter in their vehicle
stranded as they drove with the flood
water they couldn't see this man had to
be rescued as his vehicle we're told
floated on the roadway into the ditch I
talked to the 9-1-1 dispatcher who
guided us to the flooding she said even
I've got flooding in my home there is a
nearby burg Creek get this the water
went from 5 feet 12 hours ago to 36 feet
right now southeast of here there's
flooding in the city of Tulsa 11
different counties in Oklahoma had flash
flood emergencies
over the last 12
some places got six inches of rain in
six hours as we move forward throughout
the day look for the flooding and the
heavy rainfall heading into Missouri and
Arkansas David thank you